and it's not the first time you've
worked with Paul is it on the seasoning
how so
before you've worked with him he was a
prosthetics and special effects makeup
artists what's it like working with him
as a director fantastic I mean I I've
known for a long time this is what he's
meant to do he is incredibly focused and
incredibly he researches things like
nobody I've ever met he really knows
what he's talking about and he has a
very sort of instinctive way of handling
very delicate subjects thing in a very
sensitive way we mentioned there about
research without something that you were
able to take advantage over kind of his
lots of knowledge that you had about the
roles the part is he very specific and
how you wanted to play it I think it's
really important when you're dealing
with a subject like this that you really
are research into what you're doing
because you have a responsibility to
portray it truthfully you know so I
think everybody undertook a lot of
research it was very very important to
pull that everybody really knew what
they were talking about and what you
know what we were the story that we were
trying to tell for people to see it's
very intense for isn't if we can say
that I mean there's not only the kind of
emotional side but the physical side of
it as well and there's all the
claustrophobia I mean how did you deal
with like with that as an actress yeah
well I'm like any like any firm really
threw yourself into it it's sometimes
not very pleasant but you know we were
getting yourself into you choose to do
it and a lot of actors I think enjoy it
you know it's it's it's a way of
understanding what other people go
through in life I know you did a good
number a kind of sci-fi and horror
movies like music chronicles and also
hellboy two it's not something you
really enjoy doing yeah I do I never had
a plan that that was what I wanted to do
but it seems to have sort of happen that
way and I'm very happy with it it's
always very interesting so he's quite
exciting and never quite know what's
around the border
but it's fun it's a good form of
escapism doing things that you would
never normally do in real life did you
have any kind of stunts that you have to
because I know one hellboy two you had
lots of things you have to do didn't you
but do you have anything for the
seasoning house that you kind of had to
get it had a physical form yeah I had a
very cool fight scene actually with my
husband but I'm not sure how much of it
made the final cut but I love all that i
love getting really into that kind of
thing i'm always key i do quite often
make the mistake though saying yes yes
I'll do my own stunts and then end up
really hurting myself so I'm trying to
get a little bit better at choosing
exactly what i do do but it's fun fun to
get involved in it any bumps and bruises
and injuries in this film always I just
I don't know I think I threw myself and
it's slightly too much an end up I
always ice it improves quite easily I
think I can't like it there it's like
worgen to feel like doing something if
you laid in a hard day's work
what's next to you now on earth I'm do
your phone called store meet with Ian
method and that's about a woman's
journey through grief she's lost her
husband and she meets a spirit in a
house who she sort of my friends but it
also turns a little dangerous so sort of
against similar genre but yeah it's
exciting
you